les fans de jeux vidéo ont rendez-vous
ce samedi 11 février au Palais des
Sports Pierre de Coubertin de plaisir
pour la deuxième édition du plaisir
gaming au programme tournoi sur PC et
console ou encore animation pour toute
la famille avec nous pour en parler
Sébastien alors plaisir gaming c'est de
10h à 21h quels seront les moments forts
de cette journée alors le moment fort
c'est le tournoi de jeux vidéo donc il
va réunir 120 joueurs aujourd'hui on a
120 joueurs donc sur quatre jeux donc
TFT donc qui est un jeu de Riot Games
Super Smash Bros ultimate donc un jeu de
combat mais avec des personnages
Nintendo il y a également un tournoi
donc sur fortnite et un dernier tournoi
sur Fifa de 2023 voilà donc il va réunir
donc pour Super Smash Bros et pour FIFA
48 joueurs pour les autres on est sur
sur une vingtaine pour le moment
et puis en parallèle de ça on aura des
activités qu'on va proposer pour les
gens qui vont pouvoir venir nous voir et
qui ne participent pas au tournoi donc
des jeux en accès libre avec une zone
dédiée à des jeux diverses donc du
bowling il y aura des jeux de voiture il
y aura également une zone qui qui sera
plus axé sur la danse avec justement
puisqu'on avait un sujet sur sur la
bachata donc avec Just Dance et puis des
consoles rétro puisque on a voulu que ce
soit un événement familial et l'année
dernière comme ce fut le
castari
toutes ces consoles des années des
années on va dire des années 2090 2000
donc qui permettent aux parents de de
défier les enfants et aux enfants de
défier les parents aussi des fois voilà
sur des jeux qui qui confondaient notre
jeunesse voilà je suis enfin en tout cas
la mienne peut-être pas la vôtre et donc
vous avez parlé de fortnite de FIFA de
Super Smash Bros ce sont des des jeux
qui réunissent le plus de monde
aujourd'hui oui oui ce sont des jeux en
fait où il y a il y a une scène eSport
qui qui se développe et ce sont des jeux
où effectivement on n'a pas eu de
difficultés à faire le plein donc c'est
vraiment des jeux où il y a un aspect de
de vraiment de de sport c'est vraiment
le cas de le dire donc du coup on est
vraiment là dans le domaine du sport des
amateurs de jeux vidéo autour du plateau
pas mal j'avoue je joue pas mal
notamment fortnite qui est beaucoup ces
trois dernières années là ça a bien bien
marché j'ai pas mal joué
il nous reste de la place sur fortnite
vous pouvez vous inscrire sur le sur le
site de la ville de plaisir c'est tout à
fait possible pourquoi pas ce sera avec
plaisir et donc vous avez des têtes
d'affiches pour animer un peu cette
journée oui alors en fait on aura on
travaille avec un enfin on travaille on
organise cette journée avec un
partenaire donc qui va en fait faire
l'animation donc on a une retransmission
sur écran géant on aura également des
des live twitch ou des live
sur le site notamment de la ville ou sur
le facebook de la ville donc qui vont
retransmettre l'intégralité ou en tout
cas une grosse partie des tournois et
les temps forts de la de la journée et
donc est-ce qu'il y a des conditions
il n'y a pas de il y a pas de conditions
à part sur le sur la partie sur la
partie fortnite et TFT ou ce sont des
jeux sur pc donc là les joueurs doivent
Fener avec leur PC donc là on ouvrira
l'enceinte pour eux vers autour de 8h30
9h bah pour qu'il puisse installer leur
matériel FIFA et Smash Bros ultimate se
passe sur sur console et les consoles
sont fournies par par l'organisation
alors cette année c'est la deuxième
édition de plaisir gaming ça devient un
événement incontournable pour la ville
en tout cas ça glissait un événement qui
réunit pas mal de pas mal de gens
puisque l'année dernière on avait
également une centaine de joueurs on a
eu environ 700 7 à 800 personnes qui
sont venues sur toute la journée alors
on était aussi sur une sur une première
édition donc on a tiré des enseignements
notamment au niveau de la disposition
dans le palais des sports donc l'année
dernière on était vraiment sur l'entrée
pour toute la partie rétro gaming aussi
on sera vraiment dans la salle de
tournoi donc vraiment dans l'ambiance du
tournoi
et
on a aussi revu un peu un peu toute
cette partie là donc
un événement incontournable en tout cas
un événement marquant et un événement
qui plaît au plaisir ouais qui plaît aux
jeunes puisque c'est vraiment dédié à la
jeunesse c'est vraiment pour eux c'est
tourner vous attendez combien de
personnes environ
bah là c'est une deuxième édition je
sais que j'ai pas mal de bouche à
oreille je suis moi-même d'ailleurs sur
le sur le discord du tournoi et je vois
qu'il y a de la discussion il y a de
l'émulation entre les joueurs donc et
puis il y a pas mal de de maintenant de
parents qui connaissent ça et puis j'ai
envie de dire la première édition est un
succès parce que il y a eu un vrai
bouche à oreille il y a eu une vraie
réponse à des à des attentes donc je
pense que la deuxième édition sera aussi
bien oui et donc si on n'est pas joueur
joueuse gamer gameuse on peut quand même
participer à cette journée puisque vous
l'avez dit il y a des animations pour
toute la famille exactement on a même
également pour les plus mélomanes on a
un atelier de animé par le Conservatoire
sur comment faire une musique de jeu
vidéo donc on peut même attirer voilà
des gens qui sont peut-être plus
éloignés du jeu vidéo mais qui aiment la
musique ou qui aime qui aime juste
l'ambiance ou quelque chose de festif
merci beaucoup Sébastien d'avoir accepté
notre invitation si vous êtes intéressé
le plaisir gaming c'est ce samedi 11
février de 10h à 21h au Palais des
Sports Pierre de Coubertin de plaisir